mind your decisions I'm presh tell
Walker start with the square whose side
length is 20 draw a quarter circles
inside this square what is the area of
the region shaded in blue that's part
one of the question part two is to solve
for this area and part three is to solve
for this area your solution should only
involve geometry trigonometry and
calculus are not allowed I think many
people around the world who have
suggested this and similar problems
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
I credit dr. Perkins for this proof
suppose the square has a side length of
R so that we can solve this problem
generally the area of the square will be
equal to R squared now consider the
quarter circles labeled this area as a
that means these areas will also be
equal to a suppose this area's be that
means these areas will also be equal to
B finally label this area as C notice
that 4a plus 4b plus C is also equal to
the area of the square which is equal to
R squared
let's get another equation involving ABC
let's calculate the area of this quarter
circle it'll be equal to PI R squared
over 4 it'll also be equal to 2a plus 3b
plus C we now have two equations for
three variables let's get a third
equation we'll calculate the area of
this shape here to do that we'll do some
preliminary work the side of the square
is equal to R and that means the radius
of this quarter circle is equal to R and
the radius of the other quarter circle
is also equal to R we have an
equilateral triangle so each of its
angles is equal to 60 degrees let's
calculate the area of this circular
sector it'll be equal to PI R squared
multiplied by 60 degrees over 360
degrees this simplifies to be PI R
squared over 6 we can then calculate the
area of this equilateral triangle which
will be R squared multiplied by the
square root of 3 all over 4 if we
subtract the equilateral triangles area
from this circular sector we get the
area of the circular segment if we flip
this circular segment horizontally we
get the other one on the other side of
the triangle we'll add this area to the
circular sector and we get the area of
the shape that we want well simplify
this formula a little bit and then we'll
go back to our a B and C diagram so we
get that the area is equal to a plus 2b
plus C we now have three
equations for three variables and we can
very carefully solve for a B and C first
we'll eliminate C by subtracting the
second equation from the first equation
then we'll eliminate 2a by doing the
following subtraction we end up the 2b
plus C is equal to the following which
we'll substitute in to this last
equation this is an equation only in a
so we'll solve for the variable a
knowing the value of a we can substitute
back and get the value of B knowing B we
can substitute back and get the value of
C and there you go
this is the solution to our problem
we've calculated the areas of a B and C
using only geometry and a little bit of
algebra we can solve for any value of R
suppose R is equal to 20 this will be
equal to approximately 126 0.06
but I think it's awesome that we can
solve for a B and C for any value of the
side of the square now just for fun
let's solve for the area of this shape
using trigonometry
this is equal to the area of a sector
and this is the area of the triangle if
we make this equal to a triangle in the
same exact radius and the same exact
central angle we'll get the area of the
circular segment next let's consider a
triangle and use al-qasas law of cosines
it states the following if we make this
an isosceles triangle where both of
these are equal to the radius and the
central angle is equal to theta we get
the following version
we'll use these formulas to solve the
problem so this shape will be equal to
the following we first will consider
this radius we have an equilateral
triangle as before which means the
remaining angle is equal to 30 degrees
now if we draw this radius that means
the remaining angle will also be equal
to 30 degrees so the angle in between is
equal to 30 degrees we then calculate
the area of this circular segment well
change the angle from degrees to radians
and then we'll use our formula sine of
PI over 6 is equal to 1/2 we then will
calculate the value of x squared using
al-qasas law of cosines we'll substitute
in and simplify now how does this help
us well if we go back to our original
shape it's going to be equal to four of
these circular segments plus the area of
the square in between so we take four
times a circular segment and then
simplify then we have this square with a
side length of x the area of this score
will be equal to x squared which we've
already calculated we then add up these
areas and we get the area of the shape
and it's exactly the same formula as
before what I like about this approach
is that you see how the shape decomposes
into other simple shapes like a square
and a circular segment it's a great
problem and I can see why students
around the world are asked questions
like this thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
you